hi my name is amy
my name is sanjali i'm marissa cook
and i'm megan simonson and our topic
proposal was
on the identification of therapeutics to
potentially eliminate homozygous
inheritance
of cystic fibrosis from mutations in the
cftr gene
to begin with our problem statement
cystic fibrosis is an autosomal
recessive disease which negatively
impacts multiple
organs in the body resulting in a high
mortality rate
by understanding the specific gene
mutation and carriers of the disease
we can identify potential therapeutics
to prevent the passing of the mutation
to offspring
saving countless lives every year
first what is cystic fibrosis cystic
fibrosis is a progressive genetic
disease
that causes persistent lung infections
and limits the ability to breathe over
time
cystic fibrosis is also life-threatening
and people with the condition
tend to have a shorter than normal
lifespan
as you can see by the image on the right
you can see the differences
between a healthy lung and a by cystic
fibrosis
clearly the lung affected with cystic
virus cystic fibrosis
um is clogged with cystic fibrosis mucus
in the airway
on to how cystic fibrosis is inherited
every person has two copies of the cftr
gene
one inherited from the mother and one
from the father
for a person to have cystic fibrosis
there has to be a mutation in both
copies of the cftr gene
people with only one copy of the cftr
gene are called carriers
but they do not have the disease each
time two
cf carriers have a child the chances are
different as can be seen by the image on
the right
likewise cystic fibrosis is caused by
changes or mutations
in the cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator
also known as cftr the cftr gene
is located at position 7q31.2
as can be seen by the image below
surprisingly
there are over 1 900 mutations
identified that result in cystic
fibrosis
however today we'll be focusing on the
most common of these mutations
which is specifically the f508 dell
cftr gene protein background
cftr gene provides instructions for
making a protein
called the cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator
like mentioned before this protein
functions as a channel
across the membrane of cells that
produces mucus
sweat saliva tears and digestive enzymes
which are crucial for the daily
functions of the human body
so what is the function of the cftr
protein the cftr protein
creates channels on the cell surface to
allow the movement of chloride
in and out of the cell the cftr proteins
are found at the surface of the cells in
many parts of the body
including the lungs sweat glands
intestines
pancreas sinuses and reproductive system
here they act like channels with gates
that open and close to control the flow
of water
and particles such as chloride ions in
and out of the cell
by controlling the flow of ions in and
out of the cell
the cftr proteins help make sure that
there is the right balance of salt
and water in our organs as can be seen
by the image on the left
when the cftr protein functions properly
and normally
the balance of the chloride and fluid at
the cell surface remains normal
however if you look on the right you can
see
when the cftr protein does not function
properly and there is a mutation
the balance of chloride and fluids is
disrupted causing mucus in various
organs to become thick and sticky
causing various cases of cystic fibrosis
the cftr protein is composed of 1480
amino acids
and this protein contains a single chain
of amino acids that are grouped into
five functional regions called domains
there are two transmembrane domains two
cytoplasmic nucleotide binding domains
and one regulatory domain
on the image on the right you can see
the locations for all
five of these domains
here is the phelogenetic tree gathered
from uniprot and blast the human
cftr protein is most similar to that of
a chimpanzee and a gorilla
this group is a part of a clade we can
see that the protein for humans and
chimpanzees may be most similar because
they share our recent common ancestor
the most common cystic fibrosis mutation
is f508 del
and it is primarily primarily considered
to be a processing mutation
a processing mutation occurs when an
amino acid is deleted
or an incorrect amino acid is added so
in this case there's a deletion of
three base pairs in the image blow you
can see that it's ctt
um of the cstr gene leading to a loss of
an amino acid called
phenylalanine and the cf2 protein
at position 508 and because of the
deletion of this amino acid
the cstr protein can't stay in the
proper 3d state
the 3d shape and proper chloride and
water transfer can occur
and because of this the cell recognizes
that the protein
isn't able to function properly and
isn't in the right shape so it just
disposes of it
[Music]
there are multiple defects that this
mutation can cause the first one
is that a fewer cfdr proteins get to the
cell surface where they are normally
located
and the second is that cftr proteins
don't open correctly even if they do
reach the cell surface so in the image
in
the center you can see that the protein
the cfta protein is at the surface of
the cell
but there's more chloride ions on the
inside of the cell than outside which
means that it's not working properly
patients homozygous for the f508 dell
mutation have what is called classical
cs so classical cystic fibrosis causes
patients to be more pancreatic
insufficient and have more severe lung
complications than patients
with other types of mutations so this
mutation is a class
ii mutation there's six different types
of classes which affect
this protein in different direct
different ways as you can see in the
image
on the right but the class ii mutation
causes defective trafficking of the cftr
protein
and it does not in most cases it does
not reach the surface of the cell
here is an image of the ligand
interaction gathered from primo and
uniprot
there are three solubilizing mutations
in the bound atp
here here is the electrostatic image of
the protein the negative areas on the
image are displayed in red while the
more positive areas are in blue
and this is the image of the mutation f
508 del it was gathered from primal the
mutation is in yellow on the right
methods we used were therapeutic studies
from
therapeutic that were from various
studies so
these include iva kefter a potentiator
lima captor a corrector tessa caftor
another corrector tricapta another
corrector
and elephorsen which is another cftr
corrector
as i mentioned before potentiators and
correctors
um help with the cftr protein so
potentiators
increase the function of these channels
to the cell surface
whereas correctors improve the
processing and delivery
of the functional cftr protein
production correctors
correct the read through or read through
agents promote the read-through of
premature termination codons
ivacafter is a cftr potentiator that
enhances chloride transport
of cftr on the cell surface so in the
first image you can see
that there are more chloride ions on the
inside
than outside which means that it's not
working properly but after
i have a capture is added the channel
opens up and
the chloride ions are able to flow in
and out of the cell
um luma kaftar is a cftr corrector that
increases trafficking of the f508 dell
cftr
um to the cell surface so it works
together with iva cavitar
to enhance the chloride transport um i
have a cafeteria
potentiates this channel open while luma
cathedral facilitates the processing
and trafficking of the f-508 dell cftr
in a study conducted using lumakafter
and iva caftor
treatment of patients with cystic
fibrosis who have the f-508 dell
mutation
were conducted in three cohorts the
first cohort was the shorter
period of 21 days using memocaptor and
capture combination
however in the second and third cohorts
a longer period of 56 days were used
the evidence for a combination of
lumacafter and ivacafter
improves fev1 for patients with cystic
fibrosis who are homozygous
the results support further exploration
of combination treatments
tessa caftor is a corrector that
improves cfdr protein folding and
trafficking
so more mature protein appears at the
cell membrane
in a study sustaining benefit using
tessicafta which is available after
improved only three to four percent for
patients homozygous with the mutation
however it is better tolerated with the
combination of another corrector
using a triple combination therapy
tricafta is another triple combination
therapy of tessacafter ivicafter
and alexa capture modulators which
helped fix the defective cftr protein
however there are limitations for
patients 12 years and older
tricapta is only approved so
each trial the primary analysis looked
at increases in the percent predicted
forced
expiratory volume in one second also
known as ppfev1
which is an established marker of cystic
fibrosis
and in both trials tri tricafter
increased
those parameters
ileum forcing is a self-administered
treatment through an aerial soil device
it is delivered as a mist for optimal
absorption to the lungs
it is an antisense olyago nucleotide
which is a synthetic dna fragment that
binds to mrna around the f508 mutation
and the random double-blind placebo
control tester was a dose escalation
study for four weeks
it discovered that regular doses up to
50 milligrams were saved and led to
improvements in respiratory symptoms
in the graph on the right the bottom
axis represents the dose escalation
the difference between the placebo group
and the dose escalation groups up to 50
milligrams were statistically
significant we can see from this graph
that those without the treatment did not
have an improvement
just as those who took doses of 50
milligrams which was too high
in the results we have a table of
cfdr modulators approved by european
medicine's agency
as of 2020 there are three kaleido which
is ibaf
ivac tour or combi which is lima kaftar
plus iba
iva kaftar and some kevi or simdeco
which is tesla capture plus avocado
in each of these there are limitations
in the age of use
as well as mutation status the most
promising for our study
was in simchevy or simdeco
which patients heterozygous for f-508
del
almost completely lost their mutation
and symptoms as well as carrier effects
almost disappeared so this would be the
most promising for limiting
cf in family lines as i said before the
limitations such as age mutation type
and other genetic factors
make individual or combination
therapeutics
ineffective however there's a lot of
improvement by conduction
of genotype essays before drug
administration
as well as further research in types of
mutation matching two types of treatment
in conclusion clean therapy would be the
most like
the most effective option in eliminating
cystic fibrosis in families
however isn't viable so therapeutic
methods such as
ctf cftr modulators can
accelerate progress towards elimination
of this
transfer to offspring however we must be
aware that
potential combination therapies are
expensive and not everyone will react
the same
due to differences in mutations in genes
and sequences
our next steps in our study would be to
study the location target in different
sequences
of patients and how these modulators can
interact specifically with the common
f 508 dial mutation to normalize
the defect and help stop the transfer in
family lines
our references are mostly from studies
conducted using the different modulators
as well as uniprot for our protein
analysis thank you for listening to our
presentation